Dameon this idea for this film goes way
back to college but before we talk about
its story I want to talk about the math
of the musical what does a musical allow
you to do narrative Li that a
live-action film can't or doesn't or you
well I think the the the thing that I
first of all thank you everyone for
coming out it's really a really an honor
the the thing I think that I loved about
musicals for a while was just this idea
that you know I guess how you define a
musical is that if to my mind it's a
movie where when the character is
emotional enough they break into song
but to me it's a bigger idea than that
it's the idea that emotions can override
logic or you know sort of normal rules
of you know the grammar of of
non-musical filmmaking and so it gives
you this this kind of freedom as a
filmmaker as a storyteller to really let
emotion be the guiding principle which
means that you can you can really play
with the canvas you can play with the
form and and I think that was the thing
that really really excited me you know
especially at a young age watching Fred
and Ginger movies that I think when I'd
been a little kid I'd sort of enjoyed
but seemed maybe a little bit removed
from me but when I started actually
making films and watching them again
they seemed like these wild crazy
audacious borderline experimental movies
but obviously in very mainstream
packaging and in a very populist genre
at least populist at the time so when
you and Justin went to school together
start talking about this are you both
trying to kind of pay tribute to the
genre and also modernize that and make
sure that the characters in this story
live in a city
they don't live on a soundstage even if
you're gonna shoot in CinemaScope and
pay tribute to the colors and look of
the classic musical that's be grounded
in stories about people as opposed to
musical characters Justin you're nodding
yes yeah Damian was telling a you know a
modern-day story there is nothing I mean
it's hopefully a timeless story but
nothing that is you know old-fashioned
inherently about it it's a
and I was trying to you know do a
similar thing with the music which is
make music that is you know definitely
inspired by our favorite things or
favorite movies or favorite musicals but
that doesn't feel like it's actually
belonging to an older movie you know
we've loved a lot of the same musicals
the French New Wave musicals and
American musicals like singing in the
rain and you know we've been taking
those in for many years but when I
actually got down to composing at the
piano or orchestrating and I was trying
to use a language that was not belonging
to any of those eras or movies it was
just hopefully I felt honest to this
story honest to these characters to what
this needed to be and hopefully kind of
sound I mean the goal is to make
something that sounded like its own
thing and that sounded like la-la-land
Tom I want to ask about the opening
sequence where the 105-110 interchanges
closed down the idea of that shot of
that sequence is that it's not going to
have a visible edit so when you're
starting to work with damien about how
you're going to pull that scene off how
much planning goes into every little
thing that you know that when you get an
editorial that you have a way to cut
that shot cut that scene even though
you're not actually cutting so when you
start talking about that scene in
relation to filming I think we started
talking just ahead of filming I mean we
we had a lot of conversations about what
Damien was going to do with everyone and
I mean in terms of the opening a lot of
things happen in the editing room that
you don't expect so in the case of the
opening number of the traffic scene it
was really configured differently when
as originally envisioned the movie was
supposed to start with a long main title
sequence which was kind of an overture
and then it was going to go into this
traffic jam and it was going to focus in
on on Sebastian in his car then it was
going to focus in on Mia reading her
lines and then I was going to pan over
to the other cars and the musical number
was going to start and then it was going
to in the end at the end of the musical
number it was going to go back to
honking and that's when Mia and
Sebastian are honking at each other and
flipping each other off and then we were
going to go to the movie well when we
started putting you know the early cuts
in the movie together
there we wanted to try a lot of
different things because also the
opening was very long and we ended up
lifting out the traffic seeing the
traffic wasn't in the movie and so there
there was a version of the movie where
it started with this long overture this
beautiful overture and then it
introduced the characters and there was
no number and that version didn't work
at all it didn't work because it didn't
set the rules right
I mean it didn't that's exactly that's
but it has to set the rules for the
entire movie and my why is that that
that first number has to lay out the
math under which this entire story is
going to operate well I think that I
mean the reason you originally cut it
was because it was the only musical
number that wasn't sort of coming out of
the story like there's you know there's
a moment that then becomes a musical
number and so seeing it for the first
time without traffic meant there were
about 15 minutes with no musical number
and then the roommates just started to
sing and it was like what where are we
how why are they singing it was so it
was so sort of confusing without which I
guess ultimately is the the whole point
of that number is that you know
immediately what world you're in and
what can happen in this in this kind of
reality I would come back to that idea
of where our way because whenever an
actor is making a movie you can have
questions for the director and with a
musical it's going to be a little bit
different so when you're looking to talk
to Damien about the rules of this movie
and the bigger questions that you have
both Ryan and Emma with Damien what were
they and how were they distinctly
different from the questions you might
have about just a normal straight
live-action film I'll take this I think
the thing we discussed the most was how
to keep a consistency of tone and
character and so that it didn't feel
like suddenly they were different people
when they started singing and dancing
that somehow you would still feel like
they were the same people that you had
just seen in the scene beforehand and so
that's something that we we talked a lot
about the level to which me and
Sebastien know they're in a musical
mean basically I mean it's that but
their knowledge about what they're
actually in I mean is that what you're
at well there was kind of a discussion
that we all sort of had that these
characters recognize that when they're
together there's music between them and
then when we get to the fight sequence
and the record scratches you know the
music has died right and so there was
kind of that discussion that they create
this musical world which is again
probably what led to something like
traffic being you know the music is
alive within these two characters but I
don't know that that was was that the
intention from the very beginning that
those characters created the music
between them I mean I think probably not
not a no well oh yes the actors always
right right no no I think what I was
trying to say was it was you know you
have lots of ideas when you're writing
about kind of especially with the
musical you know about what the as you
say what the rule is what my math of the
world are but it really did come down to
a lot of I think just conversations with
Ryan and I'm on myself and I was really
lucky to to have the actors you know
have them not just available but but
working every minute of every day for
three to four months leading up to
shooting singing dancing piano for Ryan
and and then whenever they weren't doing
that sort of more technical training we
were talking character and we were
talking through the script and we were
talking about tone and I think two ideas
that we talked about a lot were on the
one hand this idea that yeah they create
a certain they create a sort of musical
between them which is part of why the
movie at least in my mind almost stops
being a musical for a little bit when
when that magic kind of goes away and
doesn't come back until the end in a
sort of different way and I think then
we also talked about you know this idea
of people being slightly just missed
timing the idea of being out of time you
know the idea of two characters who have
that their dreams are so informed by
eras that don't necessarily apply to LA
anymore obviously the movies informed by
older movies older music and then the
characters themselves their lives kind
of wind up it's
two ships crossing at night and there
are these sort of missed timings or
things happening at the wrong time and
that so that kind of idea I think wound
up being something that I think Ryan
first mentioned and we just kind of you
just latch on ideas like that because it
helps guide you I think another thing
that we did that helped was developing a
like a rat-tat-tat patter between the
two characters in the in the in the
scenes that weren't musical because
there's a musicality to that and there's
a rhythm to that it helps sort of keep
the music alive somehow even though
there was no actual music did those
months Emma and Ryan those months of
rehearsal dancing with your
choreographer Mandy Moore Ryan
learning how to play the piano they're
obviously requirements for the
performance but they help you understand
character in a way that you know
wardrobe may not get to have a better
understand of who Mia and Sebastian are
through that rehearsal yeah definitely I
mean I think physicality is so he's so
incredibly informative and important and
when you're moving in these musical
numbers as the character obviously
that's going to inform the way you move
through each scene and Mia being an
actress and kind of you know eventually
putting on this show I think it was it
was incredibly helpful across the board
also to find her voice because so much
of what we talked about was her voice
being very kind of light and airy at the
beginning and then she finds that kind
of belt in the audition number where she
really speaks her you know her truth in
that room and I think that sort of
process of you know developing how she
would sing throughout the film and what
it would develop to was was a very
informative gesture I'm going to ask you
about the songwriting process in what
order did you and Damien discuss theme
melody song lyric placement because all
of those things are very fluid how did
they probably change from song to song
but what would the initial conversations
say for any one piece of music yeah we
started talking right away I started
composing right away as soon as Damon
was working on the treatment for the
script and yeah we just started biting
off different things to tackle him the
first thing we wanted to tackle was the
main theme of the mood
which we call Mia and Sebastian's theme
it's the instrumental theme that comes
back over and over again because it's so
important to the story and it's so
emotionally important so we Damien felt
like he wanted to know what that was
before anything else was figured out so
I just spent a long long time at the
piano melody after melody I you know
work at the piano I spent a long time
finally I think had something really
good I send it off to Damien he says no
and then I just keep going and and then
finally somewhere in the process you
know there are some there are some that
we like but not quite enough and then
finally there's something that he just
says oh my god that's the one and took
me a long time to get there but we
finally had it and then from there on
out there were other themes other
melodies that we called you know either
you know what earning theme or you know
other melodies that associated with
other characters and he just wanted me
to start picking you know in the in the
treatment there were moments in the
movie that uh either at the ending
sequence or you know early on with with
like the roommates characters there were
moments that he knew that there was
going to be song and/or score that he
wanted me to start thinking about what
are those melodies so I started just
finding melodies at the piano every
single one was a long process and once
we felt like we had the melodies then we
would talk about how are we going to use
them and how are we going to structure
them in the song so we talked about
where's the verse whereas the chorus is
there going to be a bridge or no bridge
lost it back and forth with more piano
demos we'd structure them and then hand
them off to our amazing lyricists Benj
passuk and justin paul who would write
all the words over the melodies and and
that was just a process that never cease
to amaze me because these were at that
point locked song melodies and so there
there are you know constraints there are
so many syllables and they're doing so
much with story and character and
emotion and you know they're working off
of what I was working off of which is
the Damon's story and those moments in
the story and by that point of the
script is more developed so we knew what
the songs had to accomplish but yeah
they would they would
right they would write the lyrics and
then the songs would come to life in a
whole new way
Ryan Emma Tom Justin Damian thank you
for making this movie and sharing it
with us
and thank you so much thank you